hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow finale video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet we'll be talking a little
bit about season two they tease some
really awesome things so just careful
for spoilers here we go so much awesome
stuff happened at the end and in light
of what happened today with the upfront
Supergirl coming to the CW instead of
doing my normal top ten I'm gonna talk
about Easter eggs and then I'm gonna
talk about what is happening after this
because they've already confirmed a
couple big things like Hawkman and
Hawkgirl are kind of leaving the series
they're not gonna be serious regulars so
they might have a cameo next season but
they're not gonna be main characters
that's why they're casting a bunch of
new people and we saw our man from the
Justice Society at the end so let's talk
about Justice Society for a second holy
crap the minute I heard that I was like
oh my god I just posted a big crossover
trailer for the big four and I cross
over that they were teasing for next
year I joked about them doing just a
society like yeah I'm gonna make a
billion dollar someday they're gonna do
just the Society because they have four
big people and they have a Supergirl now
so I guess we shouldn't be surprised
that legends of tomorrow is going full
Justice Society but just because they
said just the Society in the finale
doesn't mean we're automatically gonna
jump to that and we're gonna have like a
Justice Society TV show legends of
tomorrow season 2 still has the Timeship
they still have the Waverider so we'll
be traveling in time they've gained our
man as a series regular so like he's
going to be with them in most of the
episodes then there are a couple other
characters that are casting to replace
Hawkman and Hawkgirl and presumably
whoever the big villain is gonna be who
they haven't announced yet there's a
whole bunch of Hawkman comic book
history we have to talk about in a
second but I just want to talk about
Justice Society stuff first the
interesting thing about this is that
when Teddy Sears the guy who's playing
zoom on the flash right now said when he
was cast he was cast as Jay Garrick he
didn't know anything about becoming zoom
but because he didn't know a lot about
Jay Garrick Andrew Kreisberg who's the
showrunner on the flash gave him Geoff
Johns Justice Society run to learn about
Jay Garrick now it technically is JSA
fun fact JSA was Geoff Johns first major
title at DC Comics he started writing on
it during 2000 on issue number six David
Goyer who's involved with a lot of other
comic book TV shows he wrote on comic
books for a long time David Goyer
needed help writing the title so he
invited Geoff Johns to start writing it
with him eventually David Goyer left to
work on more movie and TV stuff so Geoff
Johns took over the title and continued
to write it for a long time so JSA was
like Geoff Johns first major big comic
book that he wrote at DC but anyway if
you're looking for a deep cut on just a
society going into season 2 of legends
of tomorrow you want to learn about
those characters just read Geoff Johns
run on the title but let's talk about
our man you may not be super familiar
with him he's a big part of that Geoff
Johns just a society run but just like a
lot of comic book characters there are a
number of different versions of our man
people have taken the mantle just like
the flash with Jay Garrick - Barry Allen
- Wally West there are three different
versions of the character there's Rex
Tyler that's who we actually met on
legends of tomorrow we met the first
hour man the second hour man's called
Rick Tyler then there's Matthew Tyler he
debuted way back in 1940 so he's
old-school of Justice Society and that
actually that the title of that he first
debuted in was called adventure comics
Jeff Jones later revived that title in
2009 so we're on like the Jeff Jones
infinite loop here this is so funny how
deep Jeff Jones is embedded in DC Comics
no surprise that he is now in charge of
all their films what about his powers
though our man so he takes this pill
called miraculous and it gives him a
bunch of different abilities but only
for an hour at a time so the pill lasts
for an hour but in the comics he's not a
metahuman he takes the pills and he gets
enhanced strength enhanced durability
speed he turns into like a smaller
version of Superman for an hour at a
time
what a coincidence then that an episode
of legends of tomorrow lasts for about
an hour
technically it's 42 minutes because of
ads but you get the idea when he's all
juiced up on the pills they
affectionately call it power hour so you
can make as many jokes about that as you
want the twist is that he gets addicted
to the pills it becomes very
debilitating so we might see a version
of that on the TV show I don't know if
they're gonna do the pills or if they'll
just call him a metahuman so just a
reminder that this is Rex Tyler he is
the first version of the character he's
the one that created the drug to give
him the powers so you can kind of see
how he would work on a crossover with a
flash caitlin made velocity-9
so there are a lot of ways to cross
legends of tomorrow with the other shows
but no idea how they're going to address
the idea of the Justice Society beyond
this TV show so on arrow
on flash on Supergirl they might not
directly refer to it at least right away
maybe only during the big four night
crossover event which will probably end
up happening this fall but if you didn't
see my video earlier this week I did my
legends of tomorrow video from last week
during a Batman video earlier and I
explain what's going on with Captain
Cold we saw a version of him in the
episode from earlier in the timeline but
he's still dead in present-day what
ended up happening is is behind the
scenes Wentworth Miller the actor signed
an overall contract with Warner Brothers
television to go on all of the TV series
as a regular so he's gonna pop up on all
for DC Comics TV shows now that's all
they've said they haven't explained how
that's gonna happen because the most
current version of him is still dead he
died in the future so we'll see how they
explain that but Captain Cold will still
be on all of the TV series next season
firestorm powers though we finally saw
him uses transmutation powers they'll
probably play with that next season it
involves a lot of special effects that's
kind of expensive so don't expect him to
do it all the time like if you ever
wondered how come leaders don't form
firestorm and beat the out of you
know whoever villain they were fighting
each week it's because it's really
expensive to do special effects like
that but I almost forgot one more big
Justice Society Easter Egg I've been
talking about this for forever for the
last like four or five videos on arrow
but Marc Guggenheim wrote the last big
just society arc before the big new 52
reboot it was called like the entire run
when they collected in a trade paperback
was called Monument Point which will
sound familiar if you've been watching
arrow this season some of you may have
not but just watch my arrow videos I'll
totally explain what's going on with
that it's just that he posted this
picture it was like this is very
appropriate to post now because we're
doing just a society we were kind of
doing this story line during hero the
season you get the idea it's a lot of
fun but I promise to talk a little bit
about Hawk man's history in the comics
it is completely confusing it's
completely ridiculous so if you're
confused about Hawkman and Hawk Girls
backstory do not be surprised
everybody's confused about it nightmare
level continuity problems so we start in
the Golden Age with Prince Khufu Carter
Hall that's the one that we met here
that's the one they're doing on the TV
show during the Silver Age he was
called Carter Hall it still pronounced
the same but it's spelled differently in
this version of his backstory he was
from the planet thanagar in everybody
looked like Hawkman like imagine a world
full of people that looked like Hawkman
that's how they explained it on the TV
show Danah Guardian technology sent to
earth in the form of meteors
so thanagar exists in this universe but
it sounds like they're not really gonna
address that in season two then during
the big zero hour event they merged all
those back stories and you got one
version of Carter Hall he's from Earth
he's not the thanagarian they went with
the Egyptian origin story narrating the
process is Waverider here for which
they're Timeship on the TV show is named
it's called the Waverider after the
Waverider character of the comics so you
see there's Easter eggs all over the
place don't you feel like you have a PhD
in comic book Easter eggs now but
already you can understand how confusing
that is in how they tried to include
Easter eggs for that on the TV show like
their blood activates the thanagarian
technology so there's some Fanta gar in
there there's some prince khufu egyptian
origin story Golden Age Silver Age
coming together they kind of do that
with the TV shows because comics get
really messy with continuity if you go
back far enough overall the episode was
pretty good I did think they stuck the
landing and had that amazing twist so it
was a great finale but the series as a
whole was kind of inconsistent I think
it took them a little while to figure it
out I think it required them getting
access to some special characters
getting access to just society things so
I think all that stuff behind the scenes
as well as them having to rush the
series out just kind of contributed to
some of the early problems that they had
with the stories and now that this years
they know going into next year they
already have a season two they can start
working on it now they'll have a lot
better time to work on the big stories
and that's really the important part
getting a really awesome story the
production stuff they can actually do
pretty easily because they have the
flash arrow a Supergirl so from a
production standpoint they're a
well-oiled machine it just it takes time
to do really awesome stories so now that
they have that time I think season 2 is
going to be pretty amazing so what does
this mean though for next week's finales
of flash and arrow are we gonna see any
kind of crossover I feel like the big
Justice Society twist on Legends makes
me really crank up my expectations for
the finales of the flash
which I'm you know expecting Jay Garrick
to appear on the real Jay Garrick and
then on arrow I'm a little more in the
dark on arrow stuff just to make more
dark puns make as many damian darhk--
puns as you want the darkness take a
drink every time someone says darkness
on arrow but the tagline says that
Oliver's gonna get help from a very
surprised force now that could be a
person that could be some magical thing
just some big twist that I'm expecting
now so let me know in the comments what
do you think this finale in Justice
Society for season 2 means for next
week's finales of flash and arrow
now they'll largely have their own plot
lines to wrap up but when they do
something this big on one of the shows
it usually means they're doing something
big on the other two shows as well even
if they're not completely related so
what's gonna happen is is they drop the
teaser for the new Star Trek TV series I
meant to do that now but because of
Justice Society I had to make this video
now it's too big a deal to not talk
about so that'll be my next video so new
Game of Thrones posting tomorrow -
there's any other crazy stuff that they
released any other news about next
season on flash arrow legends I'll
totally do a video for that - this is
really like the best possible thing that
could have happened for this TV series I
am so excited they're finally doing
Justice Society well you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
for the big crossover the big four night
crossover trailer I just posted and you
can click here for this week's episode
of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight